we did a video tell her some time ago
about Mersenne primes and i off handedly
just off the cuff i said that one wasn't
a prime if i'm honest we don't say one
is prime there's a special reason for
that and we noticed that some people in
the comments said well i think i've
heard of this before but but why is that
why isn't one a prime
so what is a prime number let's think of
the definition you probably know the
definition a prime number is a number
that can only divided by one and itself
so the prime numbers are 2 3 5 7 11 13
you know these numbers so it sounds like
one should be a prime number right it
fits the definition of the prime number
it's divided by you can divide by one
and you can divide by itself which is
one and historically it was considered I
primed them by so if you're thinking
whom it sounds like it should be well
that's that's what they used to think
that's what mathematicians used to think
as well but in the end they had to
exclude it from the prime numbers I'll
pull old one one is the loneliest number
the loneliest number you'll ever do so
it's excluded for a reason there's a
really important theorem in mathematics
it's called the fundamental theorem of
arithmetic now it says that every
positive whole number can be written as
a product by multiplying prime numbers
so here it is I didn't want to write it
out so here it is every positive whole
number or integer if you like can be
written as a unique product of primes so
you can tell this is an important
theorem because it has a name and you
can tell it's a very important theorem
because it has a pompous name so what
this means is prime numbers are our
atoms like atoms in chemistry they can
be used to make other numbers by
multiplying these Prime's together so
for example 15 is 3 times 5 3 & 5 are
prime and you can make 15 from
multiplying Prime's together but there's
a very important word here in this
theorem look at this word unique now
that's not just there for decoration
every word is important unique it has to
be a unique product there's only one way
to do it now we know of course that 15
is also 5 times 3 we don't mind that
that's allowed we don't mind that
what we don't like is that 15 is 1 times
3 times 5 not only that but it's also 1
times 1 times 3 times 5 and it's 1 times
1 times 1 times 3 times 5 and so on if
one was a crime then we wouldn't have a
unique way of writing 15 as a product of
prime numbers so what this meant was
when they used to think it was prime
they had to keep excluding one from your
theorems you would have to keep saying
take all the prime numbers except for
one and we just got tired of doing that
so we just decided to exclude one from
our definition of prime to begin with so
one isn't a prime number it isn't
considered a composite number where you
make the other numbers from Prime's know
it has a category all of its own where
it's it's all only by itself but why
does this main ones not prime maybe it's
just a stupid theorem maybe the theorem
is no good why does the theorem beat
number whatever we have a choice we have
a choice to include it in that category
if we want it to I mean I primed them it
Prime's there's a word it's just a
category and it's more useful for us to
say take this list which is the list of
all the primes and it doesn't have one
on it it's more useful say take this
list and that list is 2 3 5 7 11 blah
blah blah looking at that theorem
doesn't that mean that one isn't a whole
number because one surely one can't be
made as a unique product of primes okay
so look um let's take out start with 16
okay 16 is a product of primes because
it's 2 times 2 times 2 times 2 it's 4
primes
8 is a product of primes it's 2 times 2
times 2 so I'll just divide by 2 then 4
is a product of two primes the number 2
the prime number 2 is a product of this
1 prime number and then if I divide by 2
again
I get one which is the product of 0
prying them but it's called an empty
product so we've got a product of 4
primes 3 primes two primes continue the
pattern 1 prime + 0 primes it's one and
it's not zero it's one it's called an
empty product
be it from the number one we'll be
hearing from the number one again soon
I'm sure